-Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here, you made it.
Happy Thursday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this is fun.
I saw that today
is National Prom Day.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Yeah, it's prom
in the COVID era.
I went to Catholic school,
so I was actually
socially distancing
before it was cool.
[ Laughter ]
Leave room for the holy ghost.
My advice, get a nice outfit,
comb your hair,
and spend at least one minute
in the sun
so your prom photo doesn't look
like a Polaroid
before you shake it.
[ Laughter ]
Hi -- Hi, Ladee.
Let's get to some news.
After more than two years,
the CDC is no longer warning
travelers about COVID
risks on cruises.
You know the CDC is tired
when they start releasing
statements like,
"Do whatever you want.
I..."
[ Laughter ]
At this point it's like going
sky diving.
I'm pretty sure we all
understand the risk, right?
It's like --
[ Laughter ]
And get this, in Washington,
the House is expected
to pass a marijuana
legalization bill this week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Note plays ]
And people on both sides
of the aisle have started
releasing statements
about the whole thing.
Here, check out
what they had to say.
First up, Congressman
French Hill said,
"I don't believe we should
legalize marijuana,
and I'm willing to die on this,
well, my last name."
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Congressman
Josh Harder said,
"I do believe we should legalize
marijuana, but Republicans
are making the process much,
well, my last name."
[ Laughter ]
Then Susan Congresswoman
Susan Wild said,
"Let's just legalize it so momma
can go pop a gummy and go buck,
well, my last name."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Congressman Colin Allred
said, "Yeah, let's do this.
I won't stop until everyone's
eyes are all,
well, my last name."
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman Jim McGovern
said, "If we legalize it,
maybe McDonald's will name
a sandwich after us called
the, well, my last name."
[ Laughter ]
And finally Senator Roy Blunt
said, "No comment."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
He didn't want to say --
He didn't feel
like saying anything.
Some TV news.
I read that the second season
of "Bridgerton"
set a Netflix record
for opening weekend views.
Yep, Netflix said they're gonna
celebrate the only way
they know how -- by raising
subscription fees.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in one weekend
"Bridgerton" got 193 million
hours of viewing time.
Yeah.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That's like your mom's version
of "Encanto."
[ Laughter ]
I saw that Google Chrome --
this is real --
they just unveiled a new update,
and they debuted a refreshed,
redesigned logo.
This is real.
First, here's the old logo.
Uh-huh. Now, let's see the new,
refreshed logo.
[ Laughter ]
Google is like,
"Before you make fun of it,
just remember we have
all of your search history.
Okay, just saying."
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this,
the vacuum company Dyson
is coming out with its own
noise-cancelling headphones
that have a built-in
air purifier.
Take a look at these things.
[ Laughter ]
Dyson, looks more
like Beats by Bane.
Uh, it's kind of cool.
You're just one visor away
from being in Daft Punk.
I think it's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard about a man
in the U.K.
who says that he saved a ton
of money on gas
because he drives
the world's smallest car.
Here he is.
[ Audience "Aws" ]
He's like, "Be honest,
does the blue paint job
make it look stupid?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, at an airport
in Chicago,
a drunk man scaled
a barbed wire fence,
got onto the runway,
stripped out of his clothes,
and tried to stop a plane
from taking off.
[ Light laughter ]
Yep, even crazier,
that's also how they board
Group C on Southwest.
We have a great show.